Long lines at fuel stations, drivers waiting
patiently.. but without much hope.
Most gas stations in Mexico have run out of
fuel since the government shut down a major
pipeline and started delivering gas by tanker
trucks only.
The truth is, it's really bad, because we
already went to several gas stations and we
didn't find gasoline.
It´s been three days already
It's a disaster, it's a disaster everywhere,
I've been to two gas stations and they don't
have any.
Look at this, where else do you have to go?
If there isn't any here, where else do you
have to go?
For years, criminals have tapped into pipelines,
stealing millions of litres of fuel and depriving
the state-run oil monopoly PEMEX of over 7
billion dollars in revenue.
That's according to government estimates.
This is not 'petty theft'.
We're talking about major robbery, one-thousand
attacks on the pipeline per day, 15,000 liters
stolen each time!
How do they distribute all that stolen gasoline?
Well, there was an attitude of total complicity
on the part of PEMEX
Violent criminal gangs have long relied on
fuel theft to supplement their income.
But, says the government, accomplices within
the industry also seem to be a major part
of the problem.